hello a very good morning to you Railway
workers from the rmt Union begin a fresh
48-hour strike this morning and a
long-running dispute overpay working
conditions and job security
significant disruption is expected with
passengers told to avoid traveling by
train if at all possible we'll talk to
the government last night or unable to
avert the walk out although there was a
glimmer of hope after another Union the
tssa accepted a pay offer from Network
rail so let's take a look at this
48-hour strike it's going to affect
Network Rail and 14 operating companies
Nationwide just a fraction of scheduled
trains will be running to give you a
sense of the disruption only one in five
trains ran in the most recent strike as
a result some services will start later
and finish earlier with some areas going
without any trained Services whatsoever
well our political correspondent robal
is here with me now so another 48-hour
rail strike begins there were talks last
night but clearly no breakthrough yeah
and this time in the weekend before
Christmas so crucial days for
Hospitality uh for shops for retail um
as well one in five trains um running as
you say Hugh maryman the rail Minister
had some last minute talks with the rmt
last night that hasn't averted these
strikes it doesn't seem to have produced
anything the rmt said last night though
that the minister had requested more
talks and that they were open to that so
those are being scheduled so the two
sides are still talking at the same time
as you mentioned other unions which
represent workers who work in network
rail so on the track infrastructure
engineering control rooms things like
that they have accepted the offer that
is on the table from Network rail so the
tssa and unite members have accepted
that that is the same offer that rmt
members rejected a 63 percent rejection
on about an 80 turnout last week so even
though I think people will be waking up
thinking golly more strikes it does feel
like we are maybe edging towards a place
where potentially there is a deal to be
done I think it it is it's talking to
people in the rmt though they say it is
not necessarily the pay but some of the
conditions and some of the redundancies
that are coming alongside this package
that uh the sticking points here
um essentially uh of course even if the
government can get that over the line it
is also locked in negotiations with
other unions in other sectors as well
yesterday we saw that nurses strike the
first time a strike of that bereth had
taken place in the rcn's history over a
hundred years and on that it feels like
relations between the government and the
RCN if anything have deteriorated this
week on Monday night we saw those last
minute talks they ended really in
bitterness with the Royal College of
Nursing accusing the government of
turning their back um on nurses the
government hasn't changed position this
week it is still saying it won't be
reopening the pay settlement for nurses
so at the moment that looks to be a
continuing standoff with another strike
due for next week and then ambulance
worker strikes as well on the 21st and
the 28th of December one bit of good
news this morning though baggage
handlers at Heathrow that were due to go
on strike today they are considering a
new offer so that strike for today has
been suspended yeah but as you say
plenty of others are still on the
calendar at the moment Rob thanks very
much indeed well yes so another day of
strikes but as we were saying plenty
more to come so let's take a look at
them on top of this 48-hour strike there
will be more rail walkouts on four days
around Christmas as well as in January
after yesterday's strike nurses from the
Royal College of Nursing in England and
Wales will walk out again next Tuesday
and more NHS disruption as ambulance
staff including paramedics Emergency
Care assistants and call handlers
striking on the 21st and the 28th of the
month
postal workers will stage another
two-day strike from the 23rd of December
borderfall staff will strike from the
23rd of December to the 26th and then
again from the 28th to the 31st
and driving test examiners and some
civil servants will also go on strike
this month
now four people are in a critical
condition after reports that a large
crowd attempted to force its way into a
concert at the O2 Academy in Brixton in
South London last night so let's get the
latest then Skies Milena vaselinovich
joins me now from Brixton so what do we
know about this incident
well what we know is that the police
were called at 9 35 PM last night of a
report of a crowd trying to force their
way into the auto Academy in Brixton
London Ambulance Service also attended
so did the London fire brigade now eight
people were treated four of them are
still in hospital in a critical
condition two people with lighter
injuries were treated right here now as
you can see here behind me the cord and
still in place police officers still on
scene investigation is underway but no
one has been arrested yet now The
Nepalese have released a statement about
this incident statement is by the Met
police gold command Ade Adele Khan and
it says this is an extremely upsetting
incident which has left four people
critically ill in hospital my thoughts
and prayers are with them and their
families it goes on to say a police
investigation has been launched and it
will be as thorough and as forensic as
necessary to establish exactly what
happened last night officers are
remaining in the area to provide
reassurance to the local community in
and around Brixton if you have any
information or concerns please speak
with them now there's a number of social
media videos circulating they show a
large number of people in front of the
venue some of them trying to force their
way in some of them confronting the
police officers there's also a side
street with what looks like packed with
hundreds and hundreds of people now the
artist who had his performance here
Nigerian artist called ashaki he tweeted
in hours before the concert that it was
sold out now it's unclear if people who
turned up here thought that they could
get tickets on the night or they were
hoping to get a glimpse of him
nonetheless four people critically ill
in hospital and an incident where
investigation is underway Milena thanks
very much indeed
well let's just bring you some breaking
news now on the economy and the latest
retail sales figures have just been
released giving an indication of
consumer confidence in the run-up to
Christmas so let's find out what those
figures tell us our business
correspondent Adele Robinson joins me
now from reading so Adele how's it
looking what's the picture as far as
retail sales concerned
well I'm afraid it's not looking good in
fact it is below what was expected
forecasters expected that there would be
a 0.3 rise in retail sales volumes it's
actually down by 0.3 so clearly not good
news and this off the back of a rise in
retail sales volumes in October that was
described at the time as a bounce back a
flash dawn after the bank holiday for
the Queen's funeral in September at
sales though are still well below
pre-pandemic levels across all months
even though there was that rise in
October and well below what they would
normally be at this time of year for
November as well so what it shows is
inflation is still really squeezing
households hard off the back of the bank
of England's decision to raise interest
rates by five basis points yesterday I
guess that could have been worse it
would have been higher but still really
difficult for people mortgages let's
talk a little bit further into the
detail of those figures out today from
retail sales and they do include Black
Friday but they don't include Cyber
Monday so that could skew it a little
bit although it's a fall still online
sales we're down by 2.8 non-food
purchase is also down and at the only
area to rise was food that was up by 0.9
but the thinking is is that people are
really trying to stock up on food ahead
of Christmas so there's no winter cheer
here at the retailers that we've spoken
to in the last couple of days have
actually said that the strikes politics
aside are not helping them because of
course it decreases at footfall here in
the shops and the strikes with Royal
Mail as well deliveries too so people
that want any travel disruptions going
to affect those sorts of things and of
course this is the busiest time it's
supposed to be the busiest time of year
for retailers on the ground consumer
confidence the consumer confidence index
is out today as well that's up two
points up a little bit I suppose but
it's still at historic lows so that's
not good in the days before Christmas
and it's unlikely that we'll see a
rebound in confidence anytime soon
it's a pretty sobering picture isn't it
Adele thanks very much indeed
do you say with us we've got lots coming
up for you on the show this morning
including the chair of the labor party
Alice Dodds will be with me shortly
after eight o'clock as one of the rail
strike causes destruction Nationwide
we'll be joined by the head of the rmt
Union Mick Lynch
and Signed Sealed Delivered we'll hear
the post office's tips for making sure
your Christmas Parcels will get there on
time
[Music]
11.4 billion pounds now the government
has named 400 schools which are set to
benefit from renovation projects however
statistics analyzed by Sky's data team
shows that it would cost 11.4 billion
pounds to make the repairs needed to fix
the problems in the Britain's crumbling
schools and yet it appears there's less
than half that in the budget Sky's alley
Fortescue reports
it's soaks up and then gets that heavy
that they come through the ceiling and
they collapse it's not at all any
Headmaster wants to give to a journalist
but at Russell Scott primary on the
outskirts of Manchester they need help
these are a couple of weeks old and this
is how this is happening every time we
have a downpour
this is what happens
one of the problems we've had is that
there are internal manholes yeah
throughout the building yeah and
they've lifted up and sewage has come
out from these manholes here
it's a classroom
after leaks and floods raw sewage
floating in classrooms today the
government's announced that this school
will be rebuilt it's welcome news but
won't make up for the last eight years
we're in an area that is socially
deprived and so the pressures that a
bond by communities like ours are high
sleepless nights and all that
because you've got all these children
who depend upon you've got stuff in the
school who depend upon you and we make
the wrong call at the wrong times
um it's them that will pay the
consequence
it's not just this school research
published last year estimates that the
cost of fixing schools in need of repair
would run to 11.4 billion pounds and
capital spending on education is half
what it was at its peak in 2010.
the fifth education secretary this year
says more money is coming I think you've
always got a value for money question
you've always got to look at what's
required if you understand that we've
got these challenges but to be uh to be
focused on and singled out in the budget
is one of the areas for investment
um then that's something that I think a
lot of Education secretaries would have
liked in the past as well
we spoke to others with extraordinary
stories of crumbling classrooms and
buildings falling into disrepair they
didn't want to be named for fear it
would impact any funding decision it is
the Cinderella it has been neglected and
if we genuinely do care about our future
not just of our children but surely our
economy investment has to happen and it
has to happen now
but fixing schools badly in need of
repair making up for the Lost covered
years won't be easy or cheap Ali fortsku
Sky News
as expected labor has won comfortably in
the Stratford and ermson by-election
Andrew Weston held the seat for labor
increasing his party's share of the vote
by 10 percent although turnout was less
than 26 percent
this is an appalling result for Rishi
sunak and it really is a strong strong
labor result this is a reflection really
of the Tory vote in free fall it's not
entirely a surprise based on what I've
been hearing on the doorstep but what we
need to remember is that this
constituency a third of its councilors
just four years ago were conservative
well our political correspondent Mario
Aurora is in Stratford in Greater
Manchester for us this morning so Murray
sounds like a pretty easy win for labor
here
yeah I think it was an easy win for
labor I think no one is surprised on
either sides uh that that they won this
and they won this uh quite easily as
well now I think what was interesting
about this election was the low the
turnout was actually quite low it was
under 26 turnout obviously that to an
extent is probably to do with how
freezing cold it is and people not
wanting to go out but also I think
perhaps maybe uh feelings around the
government's actions at the moment and
maybe we know it's a relatively safe
labor seat people maybe didn't feel the
need to leave their homes in the cold
for it but I think it is disappointing
for Rishi sunak I think even though it
was an expected loss at the same time it
would have been a slightly better news
for Rishi soon at this morning had they
won uh had they essentially lost
slightly at less but also I think
kirstama will be very pleased with this
result they've had that 10 swing from
the conservatives over to the labor
party and also what's really interesting
is the other smaller parties in lib Dems
the greens who came in third and fourth
they have really not done very well and
so it does suggest that those parties
aren't stealing votes from the labor
party which will be very good news for
kirstama but I mean if we look at the
numbers so the labor party got 12 828
votes which is almost 70 percent of the
vote share whereas the conservative
party their vote share went down to
2922 which was just under 16 of the vote
share so a decent drop for the
conservative party I think also we've
got to remember we've got those May
local elections coming up a lot of toy
party uh Toy MPS are very anxious about
that especially toy MPS in the red wall
and very small majorities who are
worried about the next general election
so this potentially could be a kind of
pointer toward how we could see the
local elections going but as you say
there were no surprises in this
by-election labor were very much
expected to win so I think for now kiss
summer will be very pleased which is
soon not very surprised but the question
is there's another by-election in early
2023 in West Lancashire how will that go
and will that be a third defeat for
Rishi sunak within his Premiership yeah
interesting times Murray thanks very
much indeed
so let's take a look now at some of the
day's other headlines and at least 16
people have died and more than a dozen
others are missing after a lance slip
ripped through a tourist Campsite in
Malaysia the search for survivors is
ongoing with almost 400 rescue workers
at the side in the outskirts of the
capital Kuala Lumpur
the US National Archives has released
thousands of documents on the murder of
the President John F Kennedy For the
First Time The White House says that
more than 97 percent of Records in the
collection are now publicly available no
huge Revelations are expected from the
papers but historians hope to learn more
about the alleged assassination
tax dodging and non-compliance during
the pandemic cost the government nine
billion pounds the National Audit office
says it came as hmrc moved thousands of
tax compliance staff to covid support
schemes reducing its capacity to
investigate people and businesses not
paying the right amount
Hospital emissions for flu cases have
overtaken covid-19 admissions for the
first time since the start of the
pandemic fluid missions nearly doubled
last week jumping to 6.8 per 100 000
people that's the highest level in five
years covid-19 cases are also Rising but
at a slower rate
Twitter has suspended the accounts of
several journalists who've been covering
the social media side and his new owner
Elon Musk reporters from The New York
Times Washington Post and CNN are
amongst those subject to the ban
Virgin Atlantic will operate the world's
first Net Zero transatlantic flight the
airline has secured one million pounds
of government funding to fly a Boeing
787 jet from London to New York next
year using sustainable aviation fuel
instead of kerosene it'll be produced
from waste oil and fats
today is the last recommended day to
post cards and Gifts first class for
them to arrive by Christmas the post
office says due to Industrial action by
postal workers the last day for second
class deliveries to arrive in time for
Christmas day I'm afraid it has now
passed
now Prince George and Princess Charlotte
stole the Limelight as they joined their
parents for a Christmas carol concert
last night so the royal family were at
Westminster Abbey for the Carroll
service there they are this was a
concert where the Princess of Wales
joked about her singing talents with the
star guests there and the concert came
just hours of course after the final
parts of the sussex's documentary
dropped on Netflix well during the
service Prince William read an extract
from the late Queen's 2012 Christmas
message talking about togetherness
so more strikes and another by-election
loss for the conservatives but just how
damaging is it for the government plenty
to discuss here with the conservative
peer and pollster Lord Hayward who joins
me now welcome to a very good morning to
you let's start with by-election shall
we Stratford and urmston already a labor
seat but the tourists have seen a big
cut in their share of the vote haven't
they so should they be worried at all by
that yes clearly they should be but this
is one of those results Murray very good
analysis just now where the result
itself is no surprise each of the
parties can say well it was good for us
labor got to 70 and that's a very
challenging figure the conservatives
went down by 12 percent which is
actually less than the opinion polls
we're indicating and there's a smaller
swing than two weeks ago at the jester
by-election which we discussed here so
it's
disappointing but not bad for the
conservatives pleasing for the labor
party very low turnout often you see
protest votes at by-elections midterm
don't you so how much can we read into
this as far as a general election is
concerned very little
by-elections as you say
people register protest votes if you
look back at swings in other parliaments
swings in this Parliament I've just
referred to Chester we've had Wakefield
they were larger swings than this swing
against the government this is mid-range
and in most cases the seats then revert
back to the party that held it
previously if they change hands so
nothing astonishing in relation to this
swing quite normal well some of the Tory
MPS nearby it's a Graham Brady for
example very close by will they be
feeling a little bit anxious I think sir
Graham and other local MPS will be
feeling anxious because of problems in
terms of local elections that have been
going on for several years there's been
a friend away from the conservatives in
that belt of South and West Manchester
so yes they will be concerned but as
Murray indicated you've got the local
elections next May and people will be
looking has the government solved the
industrial relations issues is inflation
coming down it started coming down this
week is the government considered to be
a credible
manager in terms of issues such as the
Northern Ireland protocol well yes and
on the issue of strikes obviously people
have been seeing them over the last few
weeks they've got weeks stretching ahead
of industrial action on the calendar
what is that doing to the government's
reputation and Rishi sunax image as a
prime minister in control does it look
like that is being damaged the RCN
clearly one doesn't want to dispute with
any part of the NHS that's a very
difficult problem in terms of judgments
for a general election where a year and
a half two years away from a general
election the other issues like the
railways Etc we're in a very difficult
post-covered set of circumstances it's
difficult to manage because they're
coming all at the same time but the
polls are actually showing an erosion of
support still General support for the
trade unions but an erosion of that
support as they run on and particularly
the rail unions striking over Christmas
and therefore keeping families apart but
what about the Health strikes that the
nurse is going out on strike how
difficult is that for Rishi sunak and
how much has he got the party on board
on this we've read in the papers this
morning that there are four former
ministers who are calling for the pay
review body which the government is Keen
to stress they're following their
recommendations they're saying you need
to go back to them because that's out of
date now before I went into the Lords I
used to spend my time negotiating with
trade unions on the management side so
I've negotiated with most of the major
trade unions uh over many years and
people from outside the negotiations
pontificating about what should be done
always used to irritate me
um and so I'm not going to start doing
it and I'm talking here about management
colleagues who were not involved in the
negotiations leave it to the negotiators
leave it they have to report to the
prime minister to the head of the RCN
and the like but it can't go on an
excessive length of time because because
that will stretch The credibility of the
Prime Minister because disputes in the
NHS are not what any government wants
well yes and do you think that the
government s stick to its current line
or does it is it going to have to shift
its position do you think I I as I say
having spent many years negotiating the
answer is I don't know uh it's in the
position of looking inwards it's getting
the advice from the negotiators it's
getting the advice from the health
secretary
they'll make a judgment on a day-by-day
basis and the general argument is we
haven't got the money to give in to
these paid demands but also they're
saying if we pay inflation meeting or
busting pay Rises that in itself is
inflationary do you think that message
cuts through to the public I think in
part it cuts through but not there is a
natural sympathy towards the Health
Service unions which makes it more
difficult to negotiate with their
the pay board which is what the health
secretary is referring to very clearly
made a recommendation the people you
referred to as saying well look at it it
was several months ago it was
pre-invasion of Ukraine pre-gas prices
and the like so it's going to be a
difficult one to tackle the other one
other trade disputes the likes of the
railways for example and Civil Service
much more easy to do deal with even the
rail unions working from home is so much
easier now that actually the impact is
far less than it might have been a few
years ago and what about the impact on
labor of strikes Richardson very keen
whenever he can to to to paint the
unions as as being in the control of
Union Barons he talks about Labor then
being Labor's payment unions being
Labor's pay masters and I mean to what
extent is that effective do you think in
trying to shift some of the blame for
the strides off the tourists oh there's
no question that it is the natural
tactic of the conservatives of the
government is to show the labor party in
the hands of the of the bar the union
Barons whether that cuts through heavily
or not I'm not sure but kirstam is
walking a fine line because he said
labor MPS labor spokesman should not be
going on the picket lines and some have
done and whether they're spokesman or
spokeswomen they they are facing an
issue themselves it's a fine line for
both sides but it's a bigger problem for
the government than it is for the
opposition okay interesting times indeed
Lord Robert Hayward always interesting
to get your analysis indeed
now the cold weather is set to continue
I'm afraid with more snow and ice
forecast across the country this weekend
well Skies meteorologist John Robinson
joins me now so Joanna I thought that
milder weather was coming but it looks
like it's going to stay cold for a bit
it is on its way it is coming but yes
certainly for the next few days we are
keeping those cold conditions it's
freezing out here at the moment down to
minus 11.5 degrees Celsius just down the
road from me here in Oxfordshire so
freezing starts and the cold conditions
like I said are going to continue
temperatures you can see here that's the
temperatures at the moment so way down
to -5 minus six in places minus seven as
well so a cold star but it's not just
the cold we're actually seeing some
heavy snow this morning there's some
heavy snow across central parts of
Scotland and that's led the Met Office
to issue an Amber warning for the area
through to midday today so we could see
5 to 10 centimeters of snow across the
central belt of Scotland this morning
perhaps 20 centimeters of snow on Higher
Ground so there is that warning in place
across there that's there until midday
and I think then the snow across that
area will at low levels turn back to
rain and the snow mainly confined to
Higher Ground so that warning's in place
there there's also a wider yellow
warning for ice and snow across um
Scotland and then also across the
northern Isles as well as a warning of
snow and ice until 10 o'clock this
morning so those are the warnings but
elsewhere across the country we're
looking at a mostly fine day plenty of
sunshine today there is some early mist
and fog around freezing fog in places
but that will lift through the morning
and there will be plenty of sunshine
across the bulk of England and Wales and
Ireland but we will see a few showers
moving in across the western parts of
Wales maybe western parts of England as
well and those showers like I said
across the northern aisle should fade
away and like I said the cold conditions
are continuing on Saturday but change on
Sunday hello welcome back now thousands
of nurses joined picket lines across
England Wales and Northern Ireland
yesterday and health leaders are
concerned that patients will put at even
greater risk when ambulance workers join
the industrial action next week well
joining me now is NHS Doctor apath Patel
who's also a fellow at The Institute for
Public Policy research so very good
morning to you nice to see you thanks so
much for coming in so nurses walked out
yesterday there's another strike next
week in England Wales and Northern
Ireland you're an a e doctor do you
support what the nurses are doing yes
yes I do
um well nurses and healthcare workers
saw more broadly have seen their pay
been eroded over the past decade or so
and over the past year it's just fallen
off a cliff and so that balance between
how difficult the job is which it's
become more difficult over the past few
years and sort of what you're enumerated
for as a result of it that mismatch has
just grown and that's what's led to
these strikes we've seen we're seeing
sort of record levels of quit rates
among nurses as well so that's one
option but for the people who want to
continue to be a nurse they're using
pretty much only voice mechanism they've
got left they've tried other ways the
government hasn't listened and so now
it's about industrial action and a hope
would be that someone will finally
respond to what they are saying and
you're not part of the dispute as a
doctor but what's your reaction when you
hear the government say we can't afford
a 19 pay rise there just isn't the money
there and we're also we're following the
advice of the independent pay review
board what do you make of that argument
well I mean the government has a pretty
simple question it should be asking
itself which is
is pay in the health service at a level
that can maintain services at the level
I want them to be at the level I'm
promising right and the answer that
quite plainly is is no so you have two
options the first option for the
government is to come and to sit at the
negotiating table and to revise their
payoffer to set pay at a level that
feels jobs to set pay at that level that
ensures NHS performs at a standard that
we all expect it to that the government
wants it to the second option for the
government is actually to come out and
to talk to voters and to tell the public
that actually public services are going
to deteriorate they're going to
deteriorate further and that we need to
get used to that there's a new normal
and that Baseline of what we expect from
the Health Service is now lower those
are the two options for the government
what they're doing right now which is
letting inflation erode wages but still
saying Services can be maintained that
just from an economic perspective is
plainly dishonest okay and they argue
that they're putting lots of money into
the NHS don't they if the isn't a
resolution do you expect to see more
strikes to come the RCN it is saying
that that is the case if there aren't
negotiations and there isn't progress we
can expect more after these the ones
next week I think that's right I think
there will be more strikes if the
government continues with its line I
suspect those strikes that come in
January will be more severe and more
coordinated and will lead to Greater
disruptions so I think I mean the offer
the RCN has made to the government which
is if you sit at the table we will
suspend the strikes that feels I think
to most people like a pretty reasonable
offer to have made but if the government
continues to say no we're saying
Hardball then I suspect the strikes to
come will be more disruptive what about
out to patient safety do you have
concerns you work in a e yourself I know
you haven't worked this week so you
can't comment on what effect the strike
had yesterday but do you have worries
that during strikes Emergency Care is
compromised
right I mean there's sort of two ways to
think about how the strikes affect
patient care there's what it means for
patients in the immediate term what it
meant for patients yesterday what it
will mean for patients next Tuesday next
Wednesday and then there's what it means
for patients over the coming months and
years so let's take each of those in
turn what does it mean for patients in
the immediate term have Services being
disrupted yes that's almost how the
strike works that's the voice mechanism
the disruption to the normal running of
healthcare services is the voice
mechanism here they've been organized in
a way to minimize
disruption to sort of critical services
so most the disruptions have happened to
outpatient services to planned care to
non-emergency operations
and sort of certain services like
children's emergency services are being
staffed at normal levels a e services
are being staffed at bank holiday level
so basically it's it's an effort to
mitigate the harms that would come
around to patients as a result of
disruptions but disruptions are
happening access to care is being
disrupted the key thing to remember here
I think is the counterfactual so
if this industrial action wasn't
happening do we have a Health Service
where Safe And Timely access to care is
the reality and quite plainly the answer
to that is is no right and that leads me
on to the second point I want to make
what's the impact of these strikes for
patients in the medium in the long term
which is if the industrial action is
successful in negotiating a better pay
offer for the nurses and for healthcare
workers well then that will lead to a
larger more satisfying more productive
Workforce which in turn will lead to
better quality care and better access to
care for patients so in the long run
this could be in patients interest and
certainly that's what nurses are arguing
of course and yet people who are in an
emergency situation are not going to be
thinking about the long term I think am
I going to get my care now and there are
warnings that next week's ambulance
strike could actually be even more
compromising as far as patient safety is
concerned do you have that worry I do
yeah
um I think the the the ambulance worker
strikes on Wednesday poses a different
sort of risk to patients and it's quite
hard to see how that plays out again
they are being planned in a way to try
and mitigate the harms that would come
around ideally that no one would become
severely unwell as a result of not being
able to access care right so that
conversations are going on between
unions and between providers to ensure
that can happen it's hard to see how it
plays out and what the unions will argue
and what healthcare workers are arguing
is that the Bull's still very much in
the government's court and they could
sit down at the table and suspend these
trucks okay well Dr Perth Patel very
interesting to get your take on the
situation thanks very much thanks for
coming in thank you
now a new rehabilitation program could
help people with long covered reduce
their symptoms the study carried out by
the University of Leeds involves a
gradually increasing a patient's
physical activity and it could help some
people overcome the devastating effects
of the virus Skies Sherman Freeman power
reports
before Contracting covid Susanna had an
active life she loved ballet swimming
and spending time with her kids but now
even that's challenging I was always
running around with the kids I'd be the
mum crawling through soft play going
down the slides and now I'm the mum
who's at home in beds while they're
somewhere else without me and that's
really really hard I'm working I um I
used to work 10 hour shifts you know the
hospital on my feet never sat down in
Urgent Care worked GP shifts and yeah
just I can't I can't even have a
conversation for more than about five
minutes without having to pause and stop
and that's really hard around 2 million
people in the UK are currently living
with long covid and the symptoms can
vary from Patient to Patient some may
experience extreme tiredness or memory
loss others are faced with chest pains
or even heart palpitations and because
the symptoms are so varied finding a
solution has been difficult
but there may be some cause for cautious
optimism as a new study which supervised
patients who gradually Pace their
activity levels has found it could help
with symptoms this is interesting
because it is giving us hope that even
though we've got such a huge burden of
long covet patients who've been
struggling for a long time now
a year and a half to two years that
there is still hope that even now if
they do the structured pacing sort of
protocol probably longer I mean we did
we tested only for six weeks so but this
study is limited and the core of the
condition still isn't fully understood
I've kind of come to a point where I
don't know what the future is and the
doctors I trust and respect the most are
the ones that openly say that you know
we don't know nobody knows we can hope
and Hope's really important but until
scientists can figure out the exact
cause of lung covid and how to manage it
people like Susanna may have to learn to
live with it Shimon Freeman Powell Sky
News
now Sky News analysis has revealed that
the government's plans to renovate
hundreds of schools is going to cost
more than 11 billion pounds and critics
say the project still won't make up for
years of underfunding
so let's get a view on this we can talk
to Tim Warford now who runs a
consultancy group that helps schools to
secure financial support at Tim Wolford
very good morning to you thanks so much
for talking to us give us a sense of the
scale of the problem if you like how
badly do schools in this country need
renovation
um on an everyday basis I I visit
schools where we are in a world of pain
we have um structural issues we have as
best Legacy asbestos issues
um poor quality toilets anyone that
wants wanders around school will be
frankly shocked at the condition in
which we find ourselves it's estimated
that as you say we're 11.4 billion
pounds in backlog funding requirements
that Rose from 7 billion only four years
previously despite whatever investment
that we make every single year we don't
seem to be able to stay on top of the
rates of dilapidation
so when the government says that they're
naming 400 schools that are going to get
renovation money they talk about
pledging 19.4 billion pounds of capital
funding to support the education sector
are you saying that's not enough
I'm saying in our sector the Cinderella
of the government estate portfolio we
actually have 50 of the Estates and
we're only funded 15 of that we welcome
every single penny that comes into our
into our sector because we are so
desperate for it
um let's talk numbers here we're talking
about 500 schools which is on the
program from 22 000 schools which are
across our estate those 10 um that those
500 schools are due to be
um constructed over a 10-year period
That's effectively 50 schools per year
um obviously in two years time we'll
probably be facing a general election
last time we had a major
um rebuilding program building schools
for the future it was scrapped in 2010
so how many schools from school
rebuilding program will actually be
built before the next general election
and what confidence May the sector have
that this will fare any better than
previous versions and and Analysis
suggests that the most acute need is in
the East and West Midlands do you see
real Regional differences
that there will be a pipe that spikes
and there'll be troughs certain local
authorities did invest in their Estates
far better than others
um it's very difficult to say because
there'll be different materials that
will be used so I think just like
anywhere there will always be Pockets
where there will be work where there
will be worse condition
um obviously the government have uh
premised the uh collection of the East
Midlands and West Midlands on their own
condition data collection program data
so that's effectively where they've
drawn it from as someone who basically
sees schools everywhere from cumbres or
Cornwall I see them it's problems in
every single local Authority in every
single County
and the Department of Education plans to
to open up bidding for the 100 other
schools in in their project give us an
idea of that process how does a school
pitch for more money for for renovation
and are there certain issues concerning
a school that get priority over others
so as I said the 22 000 schools in the
UK 11 000 now are Academy Schools half
of which of those receive formulaic
funding called the school condition
allocation the other 50 who are
basically stand-alone schools or schools
within small trusts are invited to uh
bid each year for the condition
Improvement fund and there is very very
strict guidance criteria from the esfa
very useful it produces a hierarchy of
need so from a from a school perspective
it will be
um the projects which are most likely to
be funded will be in relation to risk so
risk to life so things like asbestos
safeguarding Legionella Etc then there
will be risk to school closure so if
your boiler isn't working and there's no
hot water the school faces not opening
so there will be different levels of
criteria whereas the score rebuilding
program is is very much premised as I
said on the previous data that's been
collected by the government through
their cdcs again the qualifying criteria
was less clear in terms of the actual
bids for school rebuilding program
schools were able to nominate themselves
and did not necessarily have to
formulate a separate bid they would
receive survey visits from the esfa or
from their partners
what about what head teachers tell you
how important is it it's not just about
the physical look of a school obviously
what do they say about the impact it has
on pupils and their ability to learn did
they say that it has a manifest effect
well well of course I mean we surely
strive to to to basically ensure that we
have a fit for purpose teaching and
learning environment and it's very
difficult for for disruption to the Core
Curriculum when you've got a leaking
ceiling and children have to be decanted
from one room to another it's bound to
have a disruptive effect it's also bound
to have a disruptive effect in terms of
Staff retention and attracting staff to
a school which is effectively not at its
best it's a way of hemorrhaging staff
and of pupils basically
okay well Tim warnford thanks very much
indeed for talking us through your
experience of schools around the country
we we appreciate your time thank you
now then let's find out what the
weather's doing and how long it's going
to stay this cold
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the weekend will eventually bring
change but for now Arctic air remains in
place the Met Office has snow and ice
warnings for parts of the north today
with an Amber warning of heavy snow for
the central belt of Scotland until
midday disruption is likely
it's very cold start with a widespread
severe Frost and some patchy freezing
fog Central Scotland will see outbreaks
of snow this morning but the snow should
turn to sleet or rain at lower levels
later patchy rain or sleet is more
likely over Northwest Ireland most other
places will stay fine once fog lifts but
there'll be wintry showers for the
northern Isles and some Irish sea coasts